so what years were you with the Knicks
uh I think I was there two thousand
and 10 and 11. was I got traded this so
I got traded there I think in 2010 was
that like amari's first year
no Amari came right after me okay so
should you were you on the team with
Amari
no I never played okay or mellow I left
there went to Denver with Melo and then
mellow got traded halfway through the
season and then you ended up playing
with like Landry fields and like no I
played who was all who was all the
random Knicks uh so I played my error
was when I was there it was like okay
Thomas had came back for a second Tracy
McGrady played with us for a second
McGrady played on the nuggets the Knicks
oh nuggets is uh it was Nene okay Nanny
was a very underrated guy
um it was
mellow
uh Kenya Martin yeah but when Melo got
traded you played the year after with
that with those guys right with those
guys yeah yeah so that was J.R Smith Jr
uh what's my damn what's my uh uh Ty
Lawson Aaron to follow what was the
light-skinned dude that the Knicks
traded to the um Nick or that he they
traded into the Nuggets but he was like
kind of like borderline like you could
again this guy could be an All-Star
Aaron to follow no Aaron will fall
played for UCLA I'm talking about there
was like a forward was it a small
forward
he was a part of that Nix mellow trade
oh uh Gallinari no
[__] that's who came Wilson Chandler
Wilson Chandler okay that's what I'm
thinking now okay I said the name yeah
that's my dog yeah shout out to Wilson
Champion League shout out to Wilson bro
what would you consider your because
you've been a part of some dope teams
obviously shout out to the Pacers I feel
like the Pacers were like
one of those teams that when I think of
the best teams that never got a ring I
think of the Pacers I think I think of
the Suns
um you know I think of
a couple versions of the Suns
[__] my life
um and then I just you know but but the
Pacers I feel like legit were like
talently
if you look at the roster like one
through eight or nine like the best team
in the league a couple of years in a row
yeah man when I first came in the league
so you know when I first came to the
league it was the year after you know
Mike did the push off to uh Reggie and
hit the shot you know they win that
Series so you know they were so mad they
were licking their wounds they thought
that you know we were winning the next
year no [__] so it was a lockout
year when I came in so they were so
focused that they had training camp the
training camp started when training camp
was supposed to start because Reggie was
like so whenever the seasons do start
we'll be in better shape than anybody so
we literally they had us all everybody
was there except for I think Jalen Rose
and Dale Davis but everybody to a man
was there was Rick Smith on that team
Rick Smith was on the team too yeah so
bro we did doing all he was in and out
of the practice during that time because
he had bad food so we worked our ass off
up until like maybe Thanksgiving and
then like we'll look like [__] ain't
about to happen and remember they didn't
start until like January or the next
year or whatever but
at that time the league was all about
vets so it was like who had the best
vets at that time you know what I'm
saying and we just ran into the Knicks
and uh Larry Johnson had that four-point
play that four-point play was crazy you
know what I'm saying and that pretty
much knocks us out the box ticks I'm on
minimum way but then the next year man
we get to the finals you know what I'm
saying we get to the finals but we ran
into a [__]
unbelievable Kobe being Bryant and
[__] Shaq that you can't do nothing
with you know what I'm saying and even
we I'm gonna tell you the funny thing
about that [__] we thought we had a a
series altering moment when Jay Rose
Jalen Rose stepped under Kobe and made
him roll his ankle
we like you guys were kind of excited
like hey
hey guys old school basketball yeah
that's right go sit your [__] ass down
yes all that like that was yeah like
everybody in the locker room like yes we
got this [__] out type [__]
and [__] Kobe plays the next game
taped his [__] up kept it moving and not
only kept the movie had like 36 or
something
were you would you like did was that an
on-purpose thing you'll see guys always
try to slide under the landings well
j-roll said I mean I think he's said it
himself he did it on purpose yeah yeah
like you know you know you don't know
that you're going to make him roll his
ankle but you hope something happened
yeah you know what I'm saying and uh
like I said during that time it was no
hoes bars it was just like survival of
the fittest you know what I'm saying so
yeah I would say that it was done on
purpose
I'm assuming throughout that series you
had to have like eventually kind of
ended up on Shaq by accident maybe there
was no no
okay I I was I was uh about to have back
surgery did you ever did you ever like I
got a shack though what was it like
guarding because because they always say
he's the most dominant player of all
time and and Peak Shack I just I just
you know I don't know what you can do
really bro you pray
um
so when he was in Phoenix
um the big Cactus bro he was he was
rolling down the lane
and I rotated over to take a charge and
when I got there he's heavy I already
made the commitment and I just closed my
eyes and I said God please
and he hit me and fell on top of me but
you know it just didn't hurt I was like
surprised like boom and I opened my eyes
and he looking right at me he's like you
look at you from Jersey other than that
I would have killed you
he's like looking dead on Tommy like you
look at you from Jersey I was like thank
you big fella
but Garden Shack was it was impossible
bro but you know when you when I'm
guarding him we gotta double team him so
it's just like I'm just holding them
holding them up as much as I can and
this was my Golden State days yeah you
know what I'm saying we played small
balls so that mean now he got to guard
me on that yeah you're like the big guy
on the team you know what I'm saying so
uh but we had success like I said we
beat him every time you know what I'm
saying but uh Shaq uh
Shaq was a low bro